questions
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening and a big big welcome to
Piers Morgan I'm censored I'm Jeremy
Carl now the fatal shooting of
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell in
Liverpool on Monday has rightly stunned
Britain she was supposed to go back to
school next week instead she was shot
dead in her own home in front of her own
mother her since this death has raised
uncomfortable questions about Gangland
culture and Law and Order in a country
where crime is rising fast so tonight
we're asking is Britain facing a violent
crime emergency and how do we put an end
to the suffering I asked Pastor Lorraine
Jones whose son Dwayne Simpson was
stabbed to death in Brixton aged as 20
former met Police Superintendent Dr
Victor Elisa and reformed Armed robber
Bobby kassenger
I'm still choked up
it's like we're experiencing a horror
which we dreaded
eight years ago
and the violence has escalated
out of London across the country and a
nine-year-old girl
innocent
shot in the chest
if this isn't a wake-up call
for everybody to come together to deal
with this I don't know what it's going
to take I'm with you and and you know
what I find really frustrating is is
that we talk about it Bobby welcome to
the show
um
I wanted to do this a little bit
differently and I hope you understand
why I know you've turned your life
around but I people watching this
tonight are going
apart from the fact that we can't afford
to survive a lot of us right now
how the hell are we supposed to walk
outside the front door for fear of what
happened to that kid explain to me
how you ended up being jailed for eight
years for armed Robbie how did you get
into that situation Bobby
um peer pressure lack of opportunities
no positive role models inequalities and
ultimately beyond all of that is choice
and greed because we can talk about all
these things I've talked about the lack
of equality
um lack of opportunities but there's so
many people came from the same
environment as me who didn't choose the
lifestyle I did so I like your honesty
did you carry a gun or a knife what did
you carry um we used to carry knives um
obviously we've had guns and that before
as well but it wasn't anything that
actually ever used it was just in
participation or the robberies at the
time and it comes after deprivation as
well thinking that you need something
that you actually don't you see all
these things everyone else has and you
believe you need them but we didn't have
the rules naive we didn't have the
knowledge to know that you had to be
patient so that's why when we work with
our young people now it's all about
teaching them patience and just allowing
and waiting for your time because every
everyone that was doing these things
with me I've got over 20 people who I
can say have been killed that I knew
personally I've got another over 20 who
are doing life in prison so although
I've come out of that system I've lost
many friends along the way because of
that same system when you looked at that
news last night of that nine-year-old
what was the first thing that went
through your head absolutely shocking
because even in any form of criminality
they take part in everyone knows the
kind of saying is that women and kids
it's a no-go area so for someone to go
and do that is absolutely disgusting
when you look at her look look her in
the eyes her son was stabbed to death
you carried a knife what do you say to
her I mean I've uh um the lady many many
times and we've spoken a few times and
it's a thing that we're I know now when
I was younger I was 14 15 16. there's a
lot of that help me out you talk you're
very honest because a lot of people go
inequality or opportunity tell me if I'm
wrong yeah so many of the kids who end
up in Gans gravitate towards that that
unit because the family life isn't great
are we right to blame parents in many
instances or not no because my parents
were both hard working that there were
streets with me it all comes down to
again choices and think the fear of
missing out parents told me
be home at 8pm your friends are hanging
out so the first thing you start doing
be disobedient to your parents were
again well I'm gonna hang on a bit later
on because you you're fearing the
missing out the fun that everyone's
having what did they say when you went
to prison for eight years oh they were
disappointed they were Absol
disappointed gutted because I was in the
top set at school it wasn't like I was
someone that didn't know what I was
doing I willingly took part in the
activities that I did because I was
greedy and I wanted to
copy and
um keep up the Joneses everyone knows
had nice things I wanted to be with them
my parents couldn't really afford it but
it was my choice
um Victor uh former met Police
Superintendent
um
speak to the police the whole time Peter
blacksey would be an example and he says
that police men and women don't have the
time anymore to deal with petty crime
because they're social workers they're
mental health operatives that stat that
crimes under a thousand pounds is
something like just not being
investigated we have heard every plan
and this great desire to reduce the
levels of knife crime gun crime just the
lawlessness that we're talking about
what needs to happen what is the
solution in your mind well I mean you'll
have politicians who say that we can't
police or way out of problems but I
think the police can play a really
significant part
um you know taking what we're talking
about at the moment the examples you've
given those people involved whether it's
the offender with the gun or the
nine-year-old girls tragically shot
whether it's the 58 year old pensioner
who was stamped those people are
carrying weapons in public places now
how do we incentivize prepare our police
so they can do their work in public
places no stabbing takes place in
private you know they just have enough
Oxford Street in the premises
you don't expect the police to be in
there but give the police the
opportunity the time to do the work on
the streets it's one of the things that
actually the police are too busy no
disrespect to any of them I think
they're great but they're too busy
filling out forms and Ticking boxes on
computers rather walking the bait and
finding our Intel and doing the job that
they used to go have we moved policing
away from that common touch and that's
why we're missing out that's the first
question well that is the first question
there is bureaucracy but again you know
I guess we can't put that away because
police officers work independently and
when we want to hold them to account the
only way we can do that is through the
records that they've made and we can't
move away from that but what we can do
is reduce that bureaucracy we can
actually give the police the time to be
able to do some of the work we wanted to
do on the street and more importantly
you talk about the other issues you
describe them as social work issues well
there are other public agencies who
should be doing that you know when I was
a club I've reside for you know five
years price it up my officers will go
and deal with someone who had a mental
health problem they will spend two or
three hours now the spend is six seven
hours because the other public agencies
are not being compelled to contribute to
the work that needs doing you can't
blame the police for that because the
police can't walk away if they get
called they have to go and deal with it
Lorraine one of the things that I think
really strongly about you might agree or
disagree is I don't believe that the the
the punishments are strong enough I look
at what happened with acid they gave
life imprisonment to acid and it is with
absolutely a known fact that those
crimes are gonna do we need to be
stronger on people who carry knives and
guns most definitely my son's killer got
12 years he done half of that he's out
enjoying his life
my son's gone for good and we've been
affected for life
the sentencing needs to be
revised and modernized there's no way
you can give a higher sentence for a
robbery than for taking someone's life
my son's killer he was sentenced for
manslaughter because of how the criminal
justice system label years and how it
how it came about that he's killed my
son it's outrageous though that area
definitely needs looking at it's not
acceptable because
more and more are carrying knives and
guns and they're younger younger the
youngest child I was called by a parent
to report an incident at school was
seven years old he brought a scissors
from home a sharp one and stabbed the
other boy in the leg seven years old
Bobby yep I agree with Lorraine about
the criminal justice system I'm sorry if
people don't like it I think that the
sentencing should be much stronger and
and and I really do believe that as a
kid who perpetrated towards the gang and
was out on the street
did you think a you could get away with
it did you not consider the implications
and to you today the man that has turned
his life around and runs this football
club in Hackney and gets kids to
understand that they need to change
their lives do you think if the
punishments were greater that would help
the situation I think there needs to be
a balance I think uh you can't write
somewhere completely off
um there's some people like myself who
where prison works and there's
Rehabilitation I went to present a
certificate degree while I was in there
there's others who won't learn who come
in call back out again so there needs to
be a kind of a balance maybe someone
gets given a very harsh sentence and
then you monitor them throughout the
sentence or they're doing the right
courses are they doing the right things
are they getting a degree but but you'd
understand uh you know her son's killer
got 12 years and he's out after six
years absolutely what does that say 100
100 I I get that but I guess
um he was sentenced to manslaughter so
the court judged him to have um
committed manslaughter compared to
murder
and then he was recalled back after six
years so like what you're saying there
needs to be some restorative justice we
can't just put him in prison and leave
him there they're learning all sorts in
there and they're coming out raving mad
I don't know if this man that has shot
and killed this child has reoffended
there needs to be restorative justice do
you agree with that quickly Victor and
I've got to finish yeah absolutely there
needs to be a balance but um we need to
be very clear for those people that you
know Bobby's talking about those people
who will not respond to the imprisonment
then we need to throw the book at them
but we need to be clear there are some
people that are just so bad prison is
the only thing for them we also need
there are people like Bobby who will
respond you know to a positive input in
prison and come out a very different
person guys fantastic Bobby thank you
Victor thank you and Lorraine Jones
thank you very much indeed
right next and I'm sensor the big
question is simply this how do we tackle
Britain's gang problems we're coming
right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now Olivia
Pratt corbell's tennis's killing was the
third gun death in Liverpool this month
there were also three gun-related deaths
in London in July and a fourth in August
so the question we're asked tonight is
is Britain losing grip of its gun
control I asked auxiliary Bishop of
Liverpool Tom Williams Firearms expert
will get us and former Scotland Yard
detective Peter blexley
you tell uh a few people and you've said
today that the Liverpool Echo front page
is wrong they want to sell papers what
do you mean by that
well I think I I saw the interview with
the chief Constable at the beginning on
the first day of this and she came out
with that phrase
directed directly to the perpetrators
the echo headline was talking to the
whole city and I think in some ways it
divided the city and saying you're
either for or against I think the city
is a hundred percent against these
criminals I think the
um and the comparison with the uh
the child that died 15 years ago the
city is different since then and that
was a watershed but I know in our
schools that school that the child goes
to in within their class there are there
would be possibly four or five children
from different cultures different
backgrounds the schools are more
integrated the the people are more
integrated if you look at our hospitals
you can see where most people come from
they don't come from Liverpool they come
from all areas around the world Bishop
Williams walk down
um I absolutely understand where you're
coming from but the problem I have is
this
um and religion I think should know this
there's a difference here between right
and wrong there's a difference between
good and evil I know all about the
Forgiveness right but the truth of the
matter is by writing that page the
Liverpool Echo are simply saying to a
criminal underworld or a criminal
fraternity do the right thing and I'm
sure there are plenty of schools and
there are plenty of opportunities over
the last 15 years since that poor by
Reese died that advances have been made
but I repeat what I said at the
beginning a child is dead and what I
think the Liverpool Echo is absolutely
right on it is saying look inside
yourself look at your consciences the
problem is that cities and organizations
governments as well don't like to admit
there's a problem of course you're
saying Liverpool's fine but it isn't
with respect Bishop Williams Because a
nine-year-old child was gunned down on
Monday and I think what they're saying
is let's deal with it I think their
newspaper Airline is responsible and
correct don't you
again well I do yes I think because it's
directed to the criminals I think that
it was misleading in the sense that that
the it's a trauma for everybody and
everybody makes the right decision and
the thing when you think about the the
people of that community in particular
um the the real problems of everyday
life are funding
um food on the table
food banks and the real everyday
problems of paying for heat and then
this absolute trauma takes place
everybody everybody would be dead
against that and I think it's one of the
most awful things anyone's ever heard of
absolutely Peter blexley um we've spoken
many times before
um you I know have spent time in
Liverpool whenever we do a story like
this people will say over we're
overregging it a nine-year-old girl shot
in her own home what's the reality the
reality is there are a number of people
in Liverpool like in most of our major
cities who are Beyond contempt who
operate on a completely different plane
to anybody with any shred of decency and
they will take Firearms out onto the
streets in order to settle their scores
because they operate in an illegal world
and so you can't settle a dispute by
going to court for example and having a
judgment handed down you can't get
solicitors to exchange letters what they
do is they arm themselves they're
untrained by and large and they're thugs
they are the scum of the earth and they
take Firearms out onto the streets and
poor Olivia rest her soul is the victim
of that we'll get a security expert um
people will watch this and they'll go
it's 2022. how on Earth is it so easy in
our society to get a gun you've you've
you've brought one in we have to point
out this is a fake government you've got
a lot to say about this an awful lot to
say I mean I think people are probably
from what they've seen on TV and dramas
and movies the reality is that people
probably recognize that Firearms can
still be accessed regardless of the fact
that the legislation changed after Don
Blaine's Massacre that obviously
Firearms were restricted in terms of
certain licenses however we've seen a
huge influx of weapons coming in from
Romania from the Balkan States even from
the United States but how the criminals
operate is on different levels you have
the very major organized crime groups
that will be using the sort of military
level of uh armaments and clocks uh
Berettas those kind of weapons but then
when you scale it down to the local
scumbags and the the drug dealers
they'll be getting something very
similar to this so this is a fake gun
but the point of this is to point to
prove actually how easy it is to get
this it's frighteningly easy very very
easy indeed feed so this for example is
a gas operated CO2 operated uh pistol
now you can buy one of these for about a
hundred and fifty Euros in Calais from a
shop very simply you can bring it back
with a very very minor amount of work on
a on a lathe and Engineering this can
become what we call a far and forget so
that is a weapon where the criminal the
scumbag could use this for maybe five to
six to seven rounds before it would
actually just collapse but that's
sufficient and that could kill somebody
with a nine millimeter round absolutely
and most nine millimeter rounds now on
the black market about five pounds per
round so it's not an awful lot of money
Peter what are we supposed to do if you
can go to Calais and get that no wonder
these gang members are running a mark
what are we supposed to do last night we
talked about you know weapons we talk
about knives there was some footage
today of machetes and Leeds people going
what are we supposed to do to make our
street safe if for anything the memory
look on the screen screen now is is you
know used with machetes in leads just
attacking people just in broad daylight
how do we protect kids like Olivia we
could be here for the entire show
talking about what the police need to do
to regain some kind of control on the
streets but what we need to do
immediately is if we know something if
we've heard something we need to contact
merseyside police or Crime Stoppers
anonymously 0800 triple five triple one
and yesterday I contacted merseyside
police because I've spent a lot of time
in the last three and a half years
because I'm hunting a criminal from
merseyside who's wanted for two murders
so I've immersed myself in the
Underworld to an extent of people from
Liverpool and one of my sources
contacted me yesterday and they said
they are fairly sure that much of the
recent Spate of violence in Liverpool is
being orchestrated by a man who is in
prison now interestingly today the man
who who was arrested the intended target
of the attack who was shot and went to
hospital he is being recalled to prison
so that might add some Credence to what
I was told regardless the police will
listen to gossip rumor Tittle anything
you hear please come on do the right
thing and contact them was the paper
irresponsible gentleman briefly to the
Liverpool Echo I thought their front
page was spot on the bishop says that it
was divisive what's your response to
that both of you not in the slightest
there is no gray areas here what side
are you on are you on the side right
scumbags or are you a right righteous
upstanding person who wants to see
Olivia's murderer captured but I think
the problem is regardless of the facts
and the morals and the ethics that
people should feel obligated to report
that information through we know with
organized crime Peter will know this uh
these individuals will not tell on each
other you know snitches you don't
believe that anybody
tolerance of this attack wouldn't even
matter I'm not trying to a painter
picture that criminals have but there is
a there is an Unwritten rule am I not
right in saying that criminals when
anything happens to a kid or is there
not any morality at all are you saying
well of all the time I spent in
Liverpool a lot of the time I heard this
Mantra that people are born and raised
into believing you don't grasp you don't
talk to the police yeah there are
certain things that go beyond the pale
absolutely shooting dead of a
nine-year-old child is exactly such an
example can I bring Bishop Williams back
in um we've talked about the front page
and I understand Bishop what you're
saying there's a fear that if a
newspaper does that does it then give
the message it's not safe for the kids
to go on the street there's a lot going
on but for me it's absolutely spot on
here the people of Liverpool should be
doing everything they can to bring and
the family by the way describe this man
as scum today what's your response to
that
I agree yes I agree I'm not I'm not
saying that the echo is wrong I was
saying that it was the the they were
quoting what the chief Constable said to
talk to the families of the Vic of the
of the criminals and the people who knew
relating to what's happened what I was
saying was that is that it was addressed
to everyone it was out of context the
context was addressed directly to the
criminals families and I thought I agree
with that completely and the ones who
know them somebody knows and I agree
with what exactly everything you've said
about that thank you very much what I'm
saying is that there's a lot of good
people there absolutely there are a lot
of good people in Liverpool we make that
point and I don't think that paper in
any way was implying there wasn't I
think what he was saying the Echo and I
salute it was look it's not okay we
can't we can't dress this up somewhere
in Liverpool is a man who's killed the
nine-year-old and Society in its
entirety in Liverpool should do whatever
ever it can from whatever sector to
bring that scumbag as you quite rightly
said to Justice final word from YouTube
thank you Bishop Williams um Peter is
this situation last night we taught guns
you saw machetes there in Leeds it's
just going to get worse and worse what
needs to be done very briefly we need
the police need to patrol the streets
there needs to be greater police
presence Greater Community cohesion
greater neighborhood policing as a
priority and will I mean that yeah the
reality we need to do something about
the the ability for people to just bring
weapons into the country there are just
a variety of different routes where
they're being brought in I mean for one
example a lot of the illegal smuggling
of people coming over rarely do those
ribs come over with just people it will
have Contraband and within that
Contraband will be things like weapons
so these weapons will filter through
people can still get them you can even
look at Antiquated guns like webleies
which although the ammunition isn't
necessarily available these days you can
buy one at a market uh for maybe three
thousand pounds but it's it's not that
difficult to make the Munitions for it I
have to say you'd watch thank you both
very much indeed will and Peter you'd
watch this and you'd think I don't know
what is happening to this country
there's a cost of living crisis there's
knife crime on the streets and a
nine-year-old murdered um we appreciate
your time next and uncensored six months
of War today Ukraine on the day they
celebrate 31 years independence from
Russia as the UK pledges another 54
million query made can public support
the Ukraine survive this Dreadful
economic crisis we're coming right back
on uncensored next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back my friends now it's 31
years to the day that Ukraine declared
independence from the Soviet Union it's
also six months to the day that Russia
invaded in a bloody but so far failed
attempt to take that Independence away
with crisis and costs everywhere we turn
at home you'd be forgiven for writing
off Ukraine's suffering as a quarrel in
a far away land somebody else's struggle
after all we're all worried about food
prices uh fuel prices they're energy
shortages but remember they're all the
same thing they're all tied to Ukraine's
fight for survival and the ukrainians
fighting for their freedom are also
fighting for the fundamental principles
of our free world that's why Boris
Johnson returned to keep today restating
Britain's unwavering support
if we're paying in our energy bills for
the evils of Vladimir Putin
the people of Ukraine are paying in
their blood
and that's why we know we must stay the
course
like the billions in Aid and support
from around the world there is
absolutely no end to sight insight to
Ukraine's misery and in a nutshell this
is why Russia is illegally occupying
swathes of Ukrainian territory killing
thousands of ukrainians in the process
if Ukraine gives up this land in any
kind of peace deal Putin will simply
regroup and then come back for more
president zielinski told this show
exactly why that can never happen
we are not prepared to exchange or trade
the territory of the independent state
of Ukraine
we have no right for this first of all
we are the government because this land
belongs to Ukrainian people
and sad news this evening this just in
most civilians killed in Ukraine
President zielinski says 15 people have
died and another 50 have been injured in
a Russian Rock strike a rocket strike on
a train station so with no pause in the
misery and no imaginable ends of the war
tonight we're asking how long is this
going to go on joining me now and I'm
delighted to have a hero ruddick a
Ukrainian Member of Parliament and
tobiosel would chair of the defense
Select Committee in the United Kingdom
Kira I'll start with you I've I've said
this for many months one of the things
that concerns me is that this conflict
which is so horrendous the best way to
put this I'm not sure but becomes
it's happening and we get on with our
lives and we forget and we must never
forget these atrocities what six months
in on the day of independence what is
the feeling in the Ukraine from your own
people
uh we are happy that we are alive
and we know that being alive and still
fighting is actually a sign that uh
everybody was wrong about us you
remember the six months ago most of the
intelligences of the world were saying
that we don't stand a chance and we will
fail in like a week or two and it's six
months and we are still standing and we
are fighting and we're here to tell that
we are not giving up on our territories
and we are here to say that we will be
fighting till we win
we know that it's incredibly dangerous
that it will become new normal for the
world what's happening in Ukraine right
now and this is why we are calling for
everyone to help us to make this push to
give us more weapons to give us more
support because you see how effective
and efficient we are with it and when we
are not facing Russians empty-handed we
are able to make the progress we are
able to win our territories back so this
is our aim this is our goal and this is
where we are at the six months of war
and 31 years of Independence today of
course Boris Johnson came on
Independence Day
um announcing 54 million pounds in in
Aid if I can bring in Tobias Elwood
Tobias welcome to the show um probably a
tricky question but one I know you'll be
prepared to answer
um I think that anybody in the world
that would look at what's going on in
Ukraine knows it's not just Ukraine's
war it's the world's War but when you
consider back home uh the daily Strife
the cost of living crisis people unable
to pay their bills unable to to do very
obvious things and many families are
going to the wall do you worry the
politicians worry that people will go
it's in a far away land I I'm struggling
I'm not saying that's right but do you
have concerns that I don't know War
fatigue could set in mentally for people
yes and that's absolutely right I first
met Kim ruddick uh exactly uh six months
and four days ago uh in uh Kiev uh just
prior to the invasion nobody believed
that Russia was going to invade the
ukrainians believed it I believed it but
everybody was in denial and they thought
well this is a far-off place what's it
got to do with us they're not a member
of NATO let's leave them to their own
devices we now recognize that this isn't
just about Ukraine this is something far
bigger going on this is Russia
re-exerting itself of Putin wanting to
reinforce his Slavic vision and
influence in the eastern part of Europe
if we don't put this fire out in Ukraine
it will spread elsewhere and there is a
direct uh link between what is happening
here with that cost of living crisis
which I'm pleased you made the
connection with you know oil and gas
prices have gone up here as have food
because in part because of what's going
on in Ukraine we need to lean into this
I'm pleased our prime minister is there
committing more money but every day the
UK training spend about 40 million
pounds on ammunition 40 million pounds a
day so this isn't going to last very
long at all we need greater political
resolve to look Putin in the eye and say
we've had enough of this we're going to
stand up to you completely agree if I
can go back to Kira um what would your
message be of course it's it's very
interesting for me because I'm sat here
doing a program in the United Kingdom
and the cost of living crisis is Central
to so many people's lives and yet you're
right we look at what's going on in your
country and it pales into insignificance
absolutely but what would you say a
Ukrainian who's trying to to have a gun
who's a member of parliam who's fighting
literally personally to protect your
country what you what would your message
be to people watching this in the United
Kingdom who think we can't afford our
own lives why should we be giving money
away what would you say to them Kira
first of all I would say thank you for
your support and thank you Tobias
because you were the first one of uh
Western politicians who did believe in
what we were saying we will never forget
this
coming back to the people look we are
comparing the situation that we are
having right now with the energy crisis
and cost of living with some ideal
situation and hoping that things could
be as they were at the past but they
cannot Putin started ramping up prices
way before the war in Ukraine started it
was like November or even October and I
do not think that if Ukraine loses Putin
will come back to uh to dropping them
and will become a lovely person who will
forget about his dream of Conquering the
world does anybody even think that he
will
um he will change his behavior if
Ukraine fails so we should compare the
situation that we have right now when
there is indeed a ramp up in prices
there is indeed a very complicated
situation to the situation that would be
much worse and that would be if you
claim loses because then uh then the
energy bills would be 10 times higher
then the price of the food will be 10
times higher and then the migration
crisis that we're seeing right now would
be absolutely different it will be on
tremendous level on your show you were
talking about guns we right now give up
up to seven million of guns that only
only the ones that I know in Ukraine
what would happen if all those people uh
will will have to move to Europe what
will happen with with the general
strategy so when somebody says that we
don't have they they don't have a plan
on how to resolve situation to help
Ukraine will
I have a question how are you going to
live if we lose absolutely
I completely agree and I think that
international support for Ukraine must
continue and and and we must be
steadfast in our support and one of the
reasons we wanted to do this on
Independence Day was to make Tobias the
point to people that that it it is not
going away it does affect us all it
might as we said being a far away land
but it will impact on so many parts of
our life can I just finish tabas by
saying
um we know
um Boris Johnson was there today uh on
Independence Day 54 million we know that
Boris Johnson will cease being the
British prime minister in a couple of
weeks he has built very close ties with
zelenski and in fact some of his even
his critics said that the job that he's
done for this country in Ukraine has
been one of the highlights of his
Premiership do you believe that that
closeness that concentration on a
helping Ukraine will continue under the
new prime minister and will you be
pushing for that to bias
uh absolutely there is a bond that's
developed between our two Nations which
is second to none we've stepped forward
more than other countries have in NATO I
have to say uh straight from the start
in supporting uh our friends uh in
Ukraine but more needs to be done this
is where you need International
Leadership I'm afraid I have to say that
we're not seeing it from Britain from
Germany from France or from the United
States yes we're giving operational
equipment but we need strategic analysis
and direction of travel that shows that
we have a policy direction to stand up
to Russia we had a speech last week but
from Putin who made it very clear that
the global baton of leadership must now
be handed away from the West to a
non-west nation he was implying Russia
and indeed China that is the era of
insecurity a new decade of insecurity
that we now face this is 1937 all over
again and we need to wake up good news
babe princess Pinocchio's latest to cast
bombshell She Says Baby Arch's Nursery
called fire during their recent tour of
South Africa
the heater in the nursery caught on fire
everyone's in tears everyone's shaken
and what do we have to do go out and do
another official engagement but does the
story check out I'm joined by someone
who was actually on that tour and
disagrees back in free
[Music]
good
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back so hold on to your seats my
friends Meghan markle's in the headlines
for stretching the truth again also
tonight on the show the pope is Catholic
and bears do defecate in the woods from
where it's pumped directly onto
Britain's beaches yes Meg's at it again
she's regaled The Listener to her new
podcast with the terrifying story of how
Sun Archie narrowly escaped to fire in
his bedroom on a royal tour of South
Africa
um the heater in the nursery caught on
fire everyone's in tears everyone's
shaken and what do we have to do go out
and do another official engagement
despite being shaken in tears she and
Harry bravely and I mean bravely resumed
their duties but it turns out that
Archie wasn't even in the room when it
happened and Raul sources today told the
press that they don't even recall any
fire at all merely an overheating heater
you try saying that now this isn't the
first time Megan's face claims that a
truth isn't necessarily the truth our
investigative units and a top team of
data journalists have produced this
forensic visualization of Megan's fibs
she famously told Oprah she married
Prince Harry intimately and in secret
days before their televised bash in
Windsor the Archbishop Canterbury said
oh no she didn't Megan claims the royal
family took away her passport leaving
her a princess trapped in a tower but
investigation by our own the son found
she took at least 13 foreign holidays
During the period in which she was
apparently grounded Megan also claimed a
member of the royal household expressed
concerns about the I can't do this the
color of her unborn child's skin while
she was pregnant but she's never been
able to say who it was and she says she
barely knew anything about the royal
family the nose can't get any bigger
before she met Harry friends have said
she was a royal fanatic who visited BP
as a child and wanted to be Diana 2.0
there you go my friends lies damn lies
and the dustage of Sussex or as the
queen herself put it Recollections near
Mary joining me now is Robert jobson
Royal editor at the evening standard in
tonight's panel Esther craigie I can't
wait and former labor advisor my good
friend Richard powersaid welcome people
thank you
um
uh let's start with you Robert yeah
um why is this woman such a divisive
character why does she generate the
column inches the comments I mean she
seems to annoy slash excel in people's
brains so much why
I mean I think that the Oprah Winfrey
interview didn't help I mean that was
pretty awful as we went through the
Pinocchio stories there but look I think
it's I was talking about the guys on it
if we all landed in LA tomorrow I think
there would be a difference in the way
things to be fair to her the way we
address issues but yeah as I say I was
in South Africa on that case the the
the foreign office have issued a
statement saying that all our residences
meet the requirements health and safety
requirements
um tried contacted all the three people
that were the AIDS there today and none
of them would answer the any questions
because unlike this program I think that
the palace has somewhat censored when it
comes to Meghan Markle they're a bit
scared of they're a bit scared of what
they should say about her as well
because the reactions
um but I was there I I don't recall any
fire engines but I mean we don't get the
story obviously we were pretty rubbish
than a job but there were no stories and
the whole of the South African press
didn't cover this incident there were no
fire engines called to the residents you
know we have to ask questions about that
but she's saying that you know it was
the smoke was in the room I I tell you
what my issue is Richard just to bring
you in a sec because I know what my mate
is
I was asking the crew earlier one of the
cameras that I I sort of feel she gets
bad press but my argument would be she
comes across as lacking in ingenious she
she why wasn't this said at the time it
all seems to be this orchestrated
campaign to to gain popularity which I
sort of want to tell her she's never
going to regain you've taken your 118
million be quiet I mean it seems to me
that that you could say something quite
similar of quite a lot of different
members of the royal family yep um look
I I think uh she's not got very many
very interesting things to say I feel
quite sorry for her because I think
she's been obsessively uh kind of
slightly creepily obsessed over by the
British media do you think she thought
do you think she came from California
that different lifestyle and thought I'm
going to change the world I'm going to
modernize the monarchy I'm going to save
Harry from The Misery that he's going
through I'm gonna be this Beacon of
light and very quickly people went well
I'm not buying what you're saying love I
mean if she thought that then she was
incredibly Eve but she might quite
reasonably have thought that you know
there's one Prince who's going to become
Head of State who thinks it's fine to
undermine our democracy and sort of you
know what what was he doing taking
taking enormous donations from somebody
who his chief Aid then makes sure this
Saudi billionaire gets citizenship and a
Knighthood from the queen I mean
it'll be really rank that's what one of
them's doing the other one's friends
with pedophiles and frankly is probably
not telling the truth about it she might
quite reasonably have thought that she
wasn't going to be the most um
crystal balls we can't yeah listen you
have a right to opinion that's what talk
is all about isn't it I mean maybe she
has a point is it not the way Esther
that she does this to me it's so I was I
don't even know what the right word is
even the name of that
yes just not lacking in anything genuine
I just don't buy it but I think that's
that was her break is frustration being
part of the royal family she couldn't
curate her image for the public that's
the problem she had because I think when
you when you she said she didn't grow up
in tabloid culture fine but there is a
way you can manipulate media in the U.S
to try and sort of portray a certain
image but when you're part of the firm
your first sort of Duty is your duty to
the firm and to the country it's not
about curating the perfect image of
yourself I completely agree that you
know there are members of the royal
family that are less palatable I've
always advocated that prince Andrew
should be kept in the catacombs of Paris
that doesn't change anything that
doesn't change the fact that Meghan
Markle is completely unlikable and the
thing is that she can only milk two
years in the royal family for so long
what exactly does what else does she
have to say what else what else is there
to her you know torturous life as part
of the royal family there's nothing else
my point is this and I absolutely
support my old man worked for the royal
family for 41 years and he always said
and you talk about the part of the firm
he always said um that anybody passed
the queen mother and the queen has
systematically used the press for their
own ends whenever they've wanted it he
included Charles Diana and all of all of
the rest of them and he doesn't think
that Mystique will ever return so maybe
we're being unfair to Meghan Markle and
maybe Richard has a point that actually
if they looked at themselves uh not
William and Kate I think but but they're
all as bad are a lot of them as bad as
each other why does she goes I think
he's coming from a different angle I
think they're all found to do a terrific
job for this country so do I and I think
that when you see what the prince was
done in terms of his you know the amount
of uh well and the queen and the amount
of work they've do on behalf of the
government I think you know that's the
point we seem to forget is that the
foreign officers asked him to do this
what upsets a lot of people I think is
that Megan was around for
two minutes really you know not long
enough she didn't give it long enough I
think she could have done a terrific job
in the Commonwealth she would have given
diversity a real plus I think that
there's a lot of things that she could
have done and he just gave up on it and
I just don't this latest story she was
forced to go out on this job I very much
doubt anyone would have thought been
able to fall so let alone her own
husband to make a go on this job if she
was that distraught about it no no I
mean if there was a fire in my house I
wouldn't I wouldn't be doing this show
I'd have been at home exactly but what
was it it wasn't a fire above as well
it's quite interesting what Esther says
about likability I absolutely tell you
what I go back to the old man and he
says that when the queen dies and we've
had this discussion before he doesn't
believe the royal family or the monarchy
will ever be the same again now a lot of
people will disagree with that but the
queen I think will never we will never
appreciate what an amazing woman until
she's no more but but are they as bad as
each other is it her like but is it the
way she goes about stuff that's what it
is I don't think that the Royal Family's
success until this moment has been based
upon likability like that is not it's
hard work can graph by the queen right
exactly and you know what I was saying
but you know I think Meghan markle's uh
podcast sounds quite boring well you
know what the queen is quite boring in a
pretty impressive way right that's 70
years of her life but I don't know I
disagree with that I don't think the
Queen's boring at all when she what she
does and what she did when we really
needed it during the pandemic when he
Boris Johnson had covered when the
prince was coming down with she came in
with that that statement which great
created a sense of calm yeah when the
when the politicians couldn't have done
that when you had Boris gibbering away
and his two experts about what we should
be doing what we should be doing shown
us various grafts from school about
coven it was the Queen's words you know
we will meet again he's not going to be
able to do that
I think that the principal principle was
will be able to draw people together I
think that what Jeremy's saying is right
but he is it's a terrifically
hard-working man somebody I think yes
you'll believe it okay there are has
anything illegal been done with this
donation charity no otherwise he'd be
under investigation by the police so
that isn't the case do you think that
you think the police you think the
police would be investigating
of course
they investigated prince Andrew as to
what we're going to say I was going to
say that I think one thing that has we
all respect about the queen is her sense
of Duty and aside from the whole
likability argument we should we can go
back and forth it's the fact that Meghan
Markle never showed a sense of Duty and
that was the biggest issue I think you
know and I don't necessarily blame her
because celebrity culture in the US is
very different right there's no real
sort of there's no equivalent of the
royal family in the US you become a
celebrity you get rich you donate money
and you're a God right in the UK in the
UK it's completely different you know
there's a real this is why it appears
Morgan's in America at the moment to
begin as good stuff yeah absolutely but
you know you have that you have to be
able to read the room you have to have
respect for the British public there's
certain things you just don't do and I
don't think she completely understands I
think it's really interesting because I
can see all points I I get what you're
saying Richard actually about and if you
look at if you're born in a mirror at
the rest of them actually there's a lot
of them who aren't great I think I think
you though Robert have a really good
point as well she was there two minutes
people have done 70 years yes they'll
have made mistakes but it's about Duty I
mean look at Prince you know incredible
servant to the incredible servant to the
queen this is the strength and stay and
I just think that that just was such a
he must have been looking at this but
towards the end of his life I'm thinking
what on Earth what a shamble what's all
the great you know what's all the
graphing we don't have gone this is a
grown-up country we should have a
grown-up political system why do we have
Americans why do we have this fairy tale
nonsense a constitutional monarchy and a
parliamentary embarrassing
democracy do you want the American
democracy where you get Biden and Trump
what do you want president
I mean we could look over at Europe but
all these incredibly successful
democracies MPS if they wanted to get
rid of the market we have that by the
way got rid of the monarchy once before
then the MPS in their system we'll sort
that out look out my friends as I draw
to a close how much the American
president cost the British of the
American people and how much the
monarchy brings into British coffers but
will agree to disagree Meghan Markle
might be in your heart you might believe
she's the greatest thing since last
bread or you might believe as Piers
Morgan once said princess pinocchi only
believes what she says herself
okay my friends that's all for this
evening thank you so much indeed for
watching have a great weekend and his
peers always says whatever you do Keep
It Uncensored we're back here Monday
night from a Tara
[Music]
join me Ian Collins every day on talk TV
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues McAuliffe Alan in Grimsby
Tracy in Burton on Trent Dave thank you
very much picking apart the big stuff
this simply does not wash look who's
back under the spotlight
foreign
[Music]
good evening I'm Emily Rose Adams the
Prime Minister Boris Johnson insists the
government will announce extra cash next
month to support households during the
energy crisis it's after the regulator
off gem has confirmed an 80 rise in the
energy price cap sending the average
household's yearly Bill to
3549 pounds from October police are
questioning a man on suspicion of
murdering nine-year-old Olivia Pratt
Corbell who was shot in Liverpool on
Monday they've also appealed for
information about a black Audi thought
to have taken the intended target of the
attack to hospital and the jury in the
trial of former Manchester United star
Ryan Giggs has been sent home and will
resume deliberations next week gigson is
assaulting his former partner in
controlling and coercive Behavior
that's all for now we'll have more
updates after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]